[Musique]
je veux que tu reviennes je ne sais pas
comment m'y prendre
je n'ai jamais voulu renouer avec une
femme vient dîner avec moi ok je veux
bien dîné avec toi ce soir parce que
j'ai faim mais on parle et c'est tout
cette fois c'est moi qui t'invite qu'est
ce que tu veux un stagiaire plus de
règles et plus de secret on est où là
coût
[Musique]
juncker
tu vas rester là à regarder d'un air
ahuri oui
la réputation de votre petite amie le
précède
vous voulez devenir une femme entretenue
respecter
vous croyez être la première à vouloir
le sauver
[Musique]
deux sont quasiment comme une gamine qui
sont creusés
oui si quelque chose devait arriver je
ne me le pardonnerai jamais oh oh oh non
[Musique]